I don't know why I have been blessed
with an abundance of of good fortune in
my life
um I was a kid who always looked for the
shortcut schemer my my own family
nicknamed me Sneaky Pete
I did happen to stumble upon finding a
passion that created a seed and and
bloomed into something so wonderful for
me I can only say that I have gratitude
finally I want to just say that um I'd
like to to dedicate this this award to
all the sneaky Petes of the world who
thought a
thought thought that maybe settling for
mediocrity was a good idea because it
was safe don't do it take a chance take
a risk find that passion rekindle it
fall in love all over again it's really
worth it God bless you thank you very
much